un jeu qui était très célèbre c'était la
tête et les jambes bras plaisir présenté
par pierre bellemare
donc je vais poser des questions à
nabila et si la bella ne répond pas il y
aura des épreuves un petit peu physique
pour chacun d'entre eux on est attendu
abbassi bas si je vous le dis
[Applaudissements]
oui
attention on va de jouer pour tenir les
mots pour la première thierry moreau
alors allez-y
s'il vous plaît vous allez jouer pour
des pompes à la chantilly vous allez
devoir faire des pompes avec isabelle
assises ou qui peut sur vous mais pas le
papa beaucoup et il y aura de la
chantilly juste en dessous d'accord les
pompes à la gentillesse qu'on peut
mettre la chantilly s'il vous plaît ce
qu'on peut allez-y je vais poser la
première question
anna bin hammam était la marque et
remercie mais sa tête voilà exactement
thierry moreau mettez-vous en place mon
chéri c'est pour cette dernière
oui bah y'a pas besoin de trois
assiettes une institution cuba mais non
c'est juste sur la lazio et bercy bercy
mai à prague derrière bah oui aller à
l'hôpital de la chaux qui j'ai compris
bravo mais libre alors non on va pas
mettre isabelle morini-bosc j'avais
juste le faire comme ça bien sûr
attention là on attendait il répond pas
bon si elle est seule et ne va retomber
sur mes natation ou des têtes réponse
yoplait personne ne souple voici millage
compte sur vous voici la question qui a
pas la joconde exposée au musée du
louvre la joconde
halabi là vous avez trois secondes dit
n'importe quoi sinon la vie la caso
picasso non vie la police puis il n'a
pas la redoute picasso c'est léonard de
vinci battue attention 5 pompe bien sûr
chantilly ban avec notamment d'en bas en
bas complètement mais non je parlais de
la tête de n'ont pas fait ce qu'il veut
bien sûr si je réussis sait pas on
reprend à merci super
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'était facile
attention voici la deuxième on joue
dhabi là on joue pour gilles où gilles
verdez il doit manger un piment et
chanter à allumer le feu a porté le pima
s'il vous plaît le piment le piment
merci mamie méline venait allez on y va
merci le piment merci à la haye
ça me rappelle quelque chose de tout un
morceau de piment oui oui oui bah oui
mais alors vont croquer les revêtements
en dire moins attention nabila voici la
question tant va la cruche à l'eau qu'à
la fin elle est au quoi quoi
davila tant va la cruche à l'eau qu'à la
fin mais posez moi la question c'est
quoi c'est l'expression l'expression
c'est quoi alors dans la cruche à l'eau
qu'à la fin
faites-moi leur nana na na nana na na na
je sais pas si c'est l'expression
scénique mission j'essaie france envoie
là ce avait pas de temps réel tous à
l'eau tant va la cruche à l'eau qu'à la
fin elle tombe à l'eau oui eh bien tant
va la cruche à l'eau qu'à la fin elle se
casse elle se brise et bien gilles
verdez vous devez chanter allumer le feu
en plus un bon jeu au pied
ok pas trop ce qu'on a appris à faire
des jalouses est je sais beaucoup
d'affection dicton est toujours décalé
sur le monde c'est dérangeant
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît voici la
prochaine question joue pour enora et
nohra mettez vous plaît mais si en place
qu'est ce que je fais alors vous allez
vous mettre à vous mettre à côté de
mathieu connaît pas la réponse mais
surtout il est à côté de nabila bisous
si vous perdez nabila ou devra affronter
enora au bras de fer
quelle est la capitale de l'australie
alors la ville veut dire bah vous avez
perdu allez venez là vous allez ici
venez ici venez l'algérie je trouve la
capitale de l'australie c'est canberra
bien sûr
brad sociaux c'était moi j'ai 0 c'est
parti
en quoi refaire on refait c'était bien
mais là trop de patates à la trop patate
général sida c'est là attention
non mais non merci la vie là-bas elle
soit pour les 200 go lesquels jouer leur
vie d'ado voici la dernière c'est pour
jean michel maire jean michel maire
sachez qu on joue on joue je vous le dis
pour faire un smack à jean michel mr
aulas là c'est pas pareil
les règles changent si vous répondez mal
vous faites un smack à jean michel aulas
c'est abuser ça s'il vous répondez bien
vous ne faites pas de ce mac à jean
michel mr d'accord bas aussi la question
avec la longue à un smack langue halle
st jacques le gall oui ou non mais ça se
fait pas
[Rires]
nabila voici la question
donc si vous répondez bien pas de smac
soyons concentrés vous bien la question
plutôt facile s'il vous plaît serrées
l'une bonnes questions l'inquiétait pas
je serai toujours là la question c'est
bon facile ou aîné jean michel mr bah
jean michel mr idée née où je sais quoi
annoncer nancy ah non c'est non si vous
êtes nés ou jean michel six
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dégoûté passe à côté